so here's the thing with addictions that
I think that is universal
anything that that can control you is an
addiction
some people have addiction of
personalities like I have a friend of
mine that was an AAA who's a crack
addict he was fat he was smoking he was
doing weed all the time drinking and he
called himself an alcoholic when I met
him although he was in great shape you
know we used to we spoke phone him he's
a little short guy he's called pocket
Hercules and but he was but he was
serious about his addictions and he
recognized that he had an addictive
personality so I think the first thing
that you need to understand is it
doesn't matter if it's alcohol if it's
with spending if it's with videogames if
it's with masturbation if it's with one
itis and an unhealthy relationship with
a woman if you have any unhealthy
relationships with any vices then that
addictive personality is at some point
going to be problematic for you if you
can't say no to something if you can't
make it your [ __ ] if you can't walk
away from it for a period of time then
you're gonna have a hard time with it I
don't have that much in the way of
addiction personally I think for me if
anything it might have been video games
and I'll recognize when I spend too much
time on them that it's time to either
turn them off if it's an app on my phone
just uninstall it and realize that
there's far better things that you can
be doing with your time that are more
productive they're gonna you know teach
you something that allow you to level up
so you've got to as a guy you've got to
be able to get yourself in a position
where you're aware of your surroundings
and you understand when you've got
unhealthy addictions to things that
don't serve you and you have to be able
to make them your [ __ ] and when I say
that I mean you have to be able to say
no to them you have to be able to walk
away from them you have to be able to
let yourself know that you're not going
to be controlled by whatever it is a
foreign substance and video game and
addiction to the TV show to shopping a
woman whatever the hell it is you have
to understand that there has to be you
have to have the ability to walk away
from just about anything in your life
you know with the exception of family or
kids you know for
but even then you may have an unhealthy
toxic relationship with a family member
where you need to create some you know
some distance you know put them at arm's
length between you and that individual
and that's okay too but it's the
recognition you know it's the awareness
and most guys aren't aware of these
problems